this is the 48217 district
it became known as michigan's most
polluted postcode
residents around this corner of
southwest detroit
say their health has suffered because of
hazardous air pollutants
i was born prematurely i weighed three
pounds
and literally was born with asthma i'm
the only
cancer survivor still alive on the
street that i grew up on
i am a recipient of asthma
more than two dozen pollutant producing
facilities owned by multiple companies
are scattered across this area vicki
dobbins
says she's been feeling the weight of
industry in nearby river rouge
most of her life the people begin to ask
the question
what's going on what's in the smoke then
they start telling us
so2 co2 what's that mean
those are the things those are the
poisons and the pollutants
that are floating around in the air that
are killing your grass
because not only are you killing the
trees you're also killing people
tens of thousands of black people fled
segregation in the south
to live near here drawn to the booming
auto industry in detroit
teresa landrum said it was a utopia
but not anymore african americans
have been put into or forced to live in
areas that are polluted so environmental
racism has a lot to
do with where we live and where these
factories
and these industries are located
marathon the company which runs this
huge oil refinery
has offered to buy up homes to create a
buffer zone
it says it's reduced emissions by 80
percent over 20 years
and now produces less than three percent
in a two mile radius
local activists though insist it all
adds up
[Music]
and rhonda anderson another cancer
survivor
wants radical change the demand would be
to shut down
all the fossil fuel places all of them
they don't need to be operating the
first thing that's going to do
is help those new babies you know
because right now
our babies are doomed
before they reach kindergarten
this isn't about one firm or one place
there's toxic air lead poisoning and
water shutoffs
across america big business and
government are under more pressure than
ever before
they've got a long way to go cordelia
lynch
sky news